hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to
oh my god hi
with me george lopez let's do the show
directly right phelps
oh my god hi
uh welcome everybody to oh my god
hi with my man brian kelly hey everybody
um you know every time we start the
podcast i just want to take like a
couple minutes and just say um
you know about what's kind of going on
with me you know i live alone spend a
lot of time alone
and i spend a lot of time thinking and
you know um this year i'm going to be
60.
and you and i have known each other for
20 and change
but you don't have the kidney transplant
and you know i'm doing all right but
that's
right around my birthday it's 16 years
for that wow
so mortality i'm not sure if i'm worried
about it but i'm feeling it and i'm
starting to
miss being alive if that sounds
because i'm sick i'm going to be 60 and
i've already had that kidney 16 years so
i'm not sure how long it's supposed to
last it's not going to last till i'm
80. but it's doing great now though
right it's doing
yeah fantastic but in this
last maybe because of pandemic i feel
like i'm
um got a window of time
where before i didn't feel like i had a
window of time and
um you know when i listened to music my
child was listening all those songs like
they mean
to me something more now you know i got
the stuff going on with the house that
we'll
talk about with the movement and all
that
but but in my heart and my soul
um i mean i want to talk to ann
and mayan in the house i used to live in
so
that's if you think that's [ __ ] wow
going didn't hang out with them i
haven't done that and
since we got divorced yeah right so i
i'm feeling a little bit uh this is only
this is the first place i've said it but
i'm feeling a little bit of my
i wouldn't say mortality but i know that
i don't have original parts so
i'm not going to go 90 i'm going to go
i'm thinking like 70. wow
5. you think 15 years goes by fast so
it's not like i'm going to turn it up
and start drinking every night i'm
actually going to start to enjoy more of
my life so thank you for tuning in to oh
my god hi
this is going to be a fun show and
enough for the mamas and let's get
down to some real facts and not [ __ ]
like what i just spent five minutes
talking about it
it was it was beautiful uh but let's get
into it let's start with our
our actual name i'll probably go to
disneyland every day
in may that might work here right now
you're gonna be open
share the wealth with your mascot i'm
gonna go to the little massage parlor
right there happy massage happy star
pedal they closed
and they're all like panda express now
but i'm gonna probably go over there
every day
sweet all right well with actual news we
talked about it before what it is it's
just crazy newslines that we found
throughout the country and they're
actual news sources that we got them
from
and uh starting out from in the
insider.com
uh it's just perfect right now two
florida women dressed up as grannies
that's they said no
i try to get a covid19 vaccine
yeah so what so they put up dressing up
like granny's in florida i put i got
that [ __ ] swimsuit on
everybody's a hundred years old you have
to make yourself a hundred and fifteen
you know you could be like you for
there's they said grannies
you say uh like i'm almost 60 nobody's
come over to my house or my doctor
hasn't even called me about getting a
copa test and everybody says
i feel like i'm the girl or the dude
that [ __ ] anything because nobody's
going hey man have you been tested and
i'm like no they're like hey stay away
from bees
[ __ ] cesspool throwing cobin and i
was at the doctor today and they didn't
say like this
and even my nurse said you got the shot
i said i know dr jordan hadn't said
anything because he hasn't
so i feel like i'm walking around with
syphilis
no but of course listen and in new york
white people were going to the hood
and latino areas to try to get in line
they were using uh not
you know they can't use shoe polish i
think they were using uh
a towel they're wiping their face with
horchata but of course listen
if there's a way for people to take
advantage of their privilege they're
going to do it
dressing up like grannies dressing up
like latinos dressing up as black people
with you know and dressing up like like
the people that
black people that hired white people so
they could sell their house because
if the people that wanted to buy the
house saw that black people owned it
they wouldn't buy it
yeah right that's crazy what is this
[ __ ] gone with the wind
that's true they said it's funny they
overdid it obviously they said the pair
presented authentic vaccination cards
and then
the workers were about to inoculate the
parrot and they noticed
they quote looked funny which is nice
and then called them out so
they way overdid it and looked way way
older than they need to
and it was gone they look way older than
the kids or [ __ ]
right they should have just uh walked
behind them and screamed in their ear
and if they didn't piss
they [ __ ] got them out of line right
they said they used their real names on
the vaccination cards but uh listed fake
birthdays
they should they should have uh they
should have taken a swab that they used
for covet
put it around their genitalia where the
urine comes out
a dick or the vagina tap it test it and
if it tested
positive for urine they were they were
elderly but if there was
no urine on the swab then they were
lying and pretending to be old and they
got them out of line
all right what's the next one this one's
from the huffington post actually i
think you'll like this one
a florida man proposes that's the thing
that everybody says a florida man
a florida man this and this guy i don't
know what he was but they call him a
florida man and he proposes
using a ring stolen from another lover
so he basically he was basically a man
well yeah a florida man stole an
engagement ring and wedding bands from a
girlfriend and used them to propose to
another girlfriend
that's where he services
okay listen all right okay let's say you
go to that car dealership
and you enter in a contract with
the dealership and you say i'd like to
get into a contract with you
i promise you that i'm gonna take a car
from you
and and as long as you and i maintain
this relationship
i keep the car but if i don't pay for
the car
you're gonna come in the middle of the
night and tomorrow when i'm taking the
kids to [ __ ] lego land
the car is gonna be gone in the morning
and you know there's gonna be a dew spot
where
just drive where the car was and around
the car and you're gonna be like [ __ ]
man they can't repossess my car
how come because i wasn't paying and
then they were calling me
and i didn't call them back much like a
relationship
so you ladies you break up with a guy i
got the [ __ ] big ass ring you tell
all your friends i'm engaged look i got
the ring
and you enter into a contract and if
something happens where
the contract is not fulfilled to the
next level
which is marriage you keep the ring it
doesn't work like that
well the thing is they were still
together it said uh their
investigation never mind their little
part about that forgetting to break up
with them like a stupid ass girl
for five minutes about listen and i just
want to say mary bell i'll be home
tonight around seven
and i'm gonna stop back at caroline10
brothers
with a julie every kiss begins with jay
that's my theory
god gets it all wrong what uh they said
their
investigation started early this year
when a woman from orange city florida
told detectives that she had discovered
her boyfriend was actually engaged to
someone else
when she looked up on uh the fiancee's
facebook page she noticed a photo of her
wearing
a wedding bed engagement that was
identical to her own
in a prior marriage so she saw on
facebook
she just saw the things that belonged to
her and she was still with this guy
yeah so uh she reached out to the f uh
the orange you know what i i would i
could still say that
that relationships could be salvaged
well you never know
you never he was uh the fiancee
who lives in orlando till detectives
have been duped what about
let's say um that that area there
is the one of the most prized
possessions absolutely
and let's say that you know men
clearly don't honor it as much as women
do some women so that area there is
is very special so you meet a woman
and you're going to enter into romance
and that
really you belong to each other which
that's part of it
and she's been with you know you find
out when i
you know to honor facebook that she's
you know she blew the tennis team
of burbank high and then you're like man
[ __ ] her up i'm gonna start taking [ __ ]
from her
and that's and that's must be what he
did because some people like you know
i like that i don't think anybody else's
he said their orange zero ridge is
awesome he used two different names and
everything the orange city woman reached
out to the fiancee
who returned some of items and they both
called it off with davis who also went
by the names joe brown
and marcus brown it was joe brown with
one girlfriend
marcus brown with the other any and his
name was
something completely different davis why
dude juicing brown no he was he's black
dude
he's a black guy she would have said
that at the beginning
uh florida a black florida man that's
how it should have started
proposing listen if you don't say
african-american or you don't say latino
florida man if you just if you leave
that blank
that that's a white guy oh everybody
knows that yeah i go
i guess and he's still there how about
around christmas and someone says i want
to target that a black santa claus
instead of saying they had a santa claus
and the black santa claus would make you
don't you don't you say that
i guess i do yeah if somebody says you
know hey man i took my kid to the park
and they had a santa claus there oh yeah
i didn't know that wall was black santa
claus bought me that santa claus
but i mean like that yeah yeah that's
not me i mean yeah that's
a human nature i'm used to people being
mad at me i'm just saying that's
that's why i wanted to do one of these
shows because i think
i can't you know i'm not going to say
that all people think like that but
if you look at it yeah man and you know
you watch the news and they say
today uh um uh uh you know 17 latinos
were arrested in the back of a truck
as they tried to get into you know uh uh
houston and they got pulled over because
the registration they found they don't
say
that there's or a gunman or this
yeah and they just that's identified
it's all color coded and identifier
first that's why whenever whenever
there's a person of color doing the news
which
before there's only two white people
doing news because you know to most of
america
when you guys talk everybody believes
you
so then as more people you know like
let's say lester holt
or anna navarro who's a friend of mine
or you know brian gumbel
or uh who was uh um
i think that's it no uh and then and
then they say
you know connie chung yep or
elizabeth vargas or you know whoever
and then if there's someone of color the
white person's
always the anchor and you know why they
call the person the anchor because he
sits there and says i'm not leaving
until we account for all the [ __ ]
cameras and [ __ ] that's in here
he holds it down yeah make sure
nothing's missing at the end
well he's still out there old dave is
here by the way just according to the
sheriff's office the jail where davis
previously was booked
had a tattoo on his left arm and said
only god can judge me so
that's what his his run is but uh but
let me tell you this showtime did a
documentary called
about love it was like a it was really
good i loved the docu-series
so this was about a white dude
who would meet women on facebook and you
listen guys if you're
or women if you think you're going out
and you're going out with your friends
you're trying to escape to vegas or if
you're trying there was a newscaster
here in la
that said he was going to visit his
sister in the south and then he didn't
go he went to vegas to play golf and she
found out
and they had an altercation that made in
the news if you're going to
prote if you're going to be mistruthful
to someone
if you're going to tell them a lie don't
put it on your facebook and don't put on
social media
and don't buy a t-shirt and don't you
know
buy something from there that's going to
date you when i was in high school
i was in a relationship with a young
lady my first love i loved her
i i i i still care about you very she
was great and when you know we were
still in a relationship so like we were
together like two years
but the first year we were looking at
pictures at her house and her kitchen
table with her mom
and you know it was a real picture and
she saw this picture
and quickly like she she ditched it and
tried to hide it i said what's that
and she's like it's nothing and i go no
let me see it and she wouldn't let me
see and she bought for it let me see it
and when i finally saw it it was her and
another guy
holding hands and she said uh
that was from a long time ago and then
the guy was wearing a concert t-shirt
from a concert that was just a few
months before
and detective lopez solved the case
again and they're holding hands ah
so where to go from there um
she married a dude that picked her up on
the street had four kids and she lives
in
santa clarita all right big daddy right
here is on the walk of fame
fat bastard uh uh me i'm i'm on the walk
of fame i'm in syndication
you know movie star of an emmy uh talk
show animated
uh and i have several homes
and cars all over a picture and uh
she's out there with uh you know
huckleberry finn
fantan all right last story we got one
more story i think you'll like this uh
it's gonna be like this every week i
don't know
exactly tara bring up horrible memories
wrenching your heart every week this one
comes from
new zealand harold and uh this is a
great one 30 taliban militants
killed an explosion during bomb making
class
at least 30 taliban militant militants
have died in afghanistan after they blew
themselves you imagine the thousand that
would go
if it was an online class exactly they
teach you in person
they're like hey let's go yeah sure what
what's up guys send me the zoo
send me the zoom no it ain't on zoom man
you have to go and play the [ __ ]
you see the little screens just going
black one by one why are you guys
pulling down the blinds and two things
connecting flap
oh god that's awesome huh i mean really
man you're sitting around that guy's
like okay everybody
everybody quiet all you got to do is
take the c4
and be married gently tripped over oh
yeah right
anderson it was the green wire
it says uh the news agency uh
comma press new jc said fighters died
when improvised explosive devices ieds
uh they were learning construct
explosives inside
it exploded inside a mosque obviously
quoting a release from the afghan army
so blast happened on saturday morning in
the mosque and uh
it took out their their six foreign
nationals
the bodies of the six four nationals
could not be identified because they
were blown a bit
okay i got a great you know how you know
reese's pieces is like
chocolate and peanut butter yeah okay
that was i
so let's say you got a iud like like a
birth control device
yeah okay put a little bit of c4 in it
not a lot
and you put a little bit of c4 and then
the ladies have it and they put it
inside them
and they tell the dude if you you know
if you ejaculate in me it's going to
activate the c4
and we're both dead so if you say you're
going to pull out
pull out because
if not you're a suicide bomber we're
powder oh
right i think it's a great idea then
women can say they have it in and they
don't
and the dude's just gonna pull out
because he's gonna say do i believe her
and it doesn't count nobody believes
anything they say
it doesn't count gotcha so i have the i
have the mind of like a dude that's
like ty cobb like a chicano type cop
just the worst views on people
but that is the actual news thank you
very much for uh
your views on these i feel better
informed so great let's get moving to
our next segment though we're going to
listen to the voicemails that listeners
of this show
have left for you and if these been
edited or is this
this is real because i'll leave one for
them i think we do either they got a few
on each
these are voicemails coming from people
who actually listen to the show
818-533-1843 if you want to be a part of
it as well here's our first one
hello what's going on man it's jesse
from la i just
saw your post on ig i don't know how
much you've talked about it but i would
love to hear
um all of the uh the uh goings-on and
traditions of the uh brownie cup man
um sitting here with my daughter i'd
love to watch golf
uh say hi mama
and uh we'd love to hear about that man
i'll definitely be tuning into your pro
your podcast
the brownie cup um trophy and the
brownie cup itself
was um uh created at pebble beach
because
when you and i were doing the
amphitheater at the end of the year
uh after touring all year right after
christmas i would say to you hey man
before we go to the amphitheater let's
let's go to pebble beach and play we'll
come back the same day
yeah and then you know we started
invited and start to invite some friends
anthony and don and uh you know the
people that we took over there but then
you know kind of accidentally one of
them
or one of us uh ingested some
um brownie or candy
that had weed in it and and right around
the
eighth hole um that guy was not playing
as well as he was
in the beginning so then when he teed
off on 10 he kind of rolled it
and then we were like what's up dude he
goes oh man i ate that weed and he goes
i said oh wait a minute why don't we all
eat it
and then from the it will probably kick
in by the tenth hole so
we'll eat it on the 90 and play the
ninth hole
go to the turn get a double vodka
cranberry everybody
whatever anybody ingested on the back
nine everybody had to ingest
so if you were losing you could once
say why don't we all have another double
vodka and cranberry and
everybody had to have it you can only do
that once almost like phoning a friend
so then in the beginning you play nine
holes completely sober
and then you play the back nine under
the influence of a marijuana brownie
and a double cranberry and then you
count every single stroke
and then at the end we would go to the
tap room and then the first year we did
it you were there right
i believe i was a first year and then
the first year we did it we didn't have
a name
or a trophy and then
across at pebble beach they have that
guy kip that has that uh memorabilia
thing and i walked over there that guy
would sell his mom if
he could get a pebble beach logo on her
and
i found this old trophy from the 30s
that was kind of a cup and i bought it
it was kind of expensive it was like
three grand
and then i walked it over to all of us
at lunch and i said here's a trophy
and then we sat around thinking of a
name
and somebody said like cannabis cup or
the
weed invitational and i think it was uh
someone else i don't want to say their
names for their privacy
but actor and i think he i think he said
what about the brownie cup and then that
was the first year
so the winner of that year
was me i think you won the very first
the inaugural i won the first one
and then we decided that we would play
every year
at the end of the year and then that
trophy would go to the winner
of um of the
of the brownie cup for that year and
then he would get it back so
i won uh anthony one don cheadle won
and currently the brownie cup
is with mr d.l hughley so uh which i
would contend
that since he didn't play with us and
one other thing in the broniecos
everybody had to play together so that
you couldn't say yeah no i drank i drank
with you guys drank hey i don't believe
deal hugely
check the rules i'm gonna say i'm i'm
with the people at fox news
that i don't believe in that word he
said so so uh yeah so that's that's the
brownie cube and it's
most fun you'll ever have on a golf
course by the way remember that time we
played at uh
at madison and we teed off at uh like 10
and it got dark at 5 30 and we didn't
finish
hey that trophy's more coveted than the
claret joker guys are
going for it i mean seriously it's a big
deal to win this thing and uh a couple
of years because of schedule we didn't
play we're gonna try to play
even some of the other guys say how
about that brownie cup so uh
when i would walk down every morning to
get coffee and i would see it i felt
like a champion
and now that it's not with me i feel
like i gotta get it i feel like i could
lose
it's so great though the first nine is
so quiet everybody's mellow and kind of
you're trying to save them up you're
trying to save like
points like you know what'd you take
there i had a bogey
and if someone says oh man i tripled
those things will come back
and bite you because you know 10 11 12
that's when you're going to follow
this and this is how uh
cheech played one year and you think you
know teachers are marijuana you know
and uh you know who's more you know so
you go if you were to say
anthony don george and and and cheech
who wins i think all the money would
have been on cheech
but tommy chong said after how did
cheese play go oh i played horrible he
goes yeah
because cheech can't eat edibles man
like
like you know he he wigs out and she
said one time that somebody gave him
uh an edible and that she chatted in the
room like he was trying to relax
and then the room service got knocked on
the door when he opened the door he said
it was like the grim reaper with the
pitchfork and the whole black face with
the two eye holes
he goes man
you know he was and he said he can't
play and i remember i gave chicha
a dozen golf balls callaways and he
[ __ ] probably used 11 of them on the
[ __ ]
12th tee i said hey you have to use all
of them on one hole
and then dom was like pull the pulley on
him like hey man
stop counting choose your strokes
because there's no way oh man that he
would come back and win but he did play
and uh
anthony kim presented the trophy one
year oh brilliant uh at a mexican
restaurant in the desert
and it's been it's been great one of the
great greatest things we
do in most fun things a great idea okay
brilliant that's a good one
okay all right and next
my name is patricia i'm from boston and
um i just wanted to call and say first
of all i'm a huge fan and second of all
i just wonder if you could give me a
little bit
of dating advice um just you know from
someone who has
lived a full fulfilling life and
probably has a lot more experience than
me and from the male perspective
i've been talking to this guy for like
six months and you know it's coveted
quarantine and he was very much uh
pushing to
see me in person physically you know all
that
and uh you know we finally hung out
inside together
right and then you know uh ever since
then he's been just kind of like
distant but still checks in and still
says out of the blue
hey how's it going i want to see you but
i can't because kovitch
basically at what point do i just
say okay he got what he wanted he's gone
whatever what point should i stop
responding
basically like is this is this just
going nowhere or is it truly
uh just a coveted problem what would you
do in your circumstance if you uh
if you were this dude all right
let me know thank you i'm so excited to
hear from you
what do you want to what would you say
let's
let them hear what you have to say and
then i'll answer because i
i already know what i'm going to say
what are you going to say if you're the
guy she asked if yours
or the woman i mean how could she say
that she gave herself to that dude and
she's like
what would you do if you were the guy i
would stop calling you
you know what the guy's gonna do he's
gonna he's gonna go around and do what
he needs to do and then when there's
nothing else around he knows
he can give a call in my humble opinion
he'll he'll give a ring when he's ready
to give a ring
he's not going to jump on it it sounds
like everybody's a little different but
she sounded like she pegged him
he got in there and that was it and well
that's i think that's right
and you know there's different levels of
relationship so if it's just a sexual
thing which clearly
to her she didn't want to do to come
over because it's coveted like
yeah get to have people coming up with a
baby all kind of fluids everywhere
hey take it easy kovid you know
so so i would say that you know you have
to say what you want but i mean this is
i mean you know
you know for the whole world it's been a
time where you know so many people have
lost their lives that aside from that
like
it's not the best time to start a
relationship it's not the best time to
have somebody to rely on because
there's just you know you you would want
people to get tested like
people don't come over to my house a lot
of people don't go over your house
or nobody goes to any restaurants and if
you're working in any type of business
you gotta get tested i was doing a show
this week and i had
i had five four tests and i was there i
was there
five days wow so i would say you know
god bless you thank you for being a fan
and all that but
i think you know if you wanted to have
him be
a boyfriend then you should not have
uh given in to him but if he wanted him
to just be
you know then you know you did the right
thing but clearly it sounded like
that wasn't your thing and now like you
said he got what he wanted like any guy
that gets what he wants
but you could always test the theory
though you can call him and say hey you
want to come over
and see how that lays out and then
you'll know for sure but what would you
do if you're her
what do you do if you're i think i would
do what you said i think i would i would
play the game with them yeah
and say you know lead them you know just
do what you do and just say hey
you know uh i miss you i thought we had
a great night you know
let's see each other and i i bet you'd
tell that guy you know can you be here
in an hour because i'm leaving tomorrow
out of town i bet that dude will be
there in an hour eight hours by the way
and that'll tell you exactly what he's
about let's queue up another one here we
go
george my name is tony um i saw
a show that you were hosting back in
at the laugh factory uh there's a huge
line you were you were like the nc or
something like that introducing the
comics
but uh i always uh ever since then i
always thought you were a stand-up guy
man
uh my late wife at that time
was uh she she was disabled she had a
muscular
uh a hereditary disease and uh so she
couldn't stand in the line
so uh we asked if she could sit in the
little cubby area right there before you
get into the
um last factory and um so
you brought her a chair out for her to
sit down
and you brought her a drink you didn't
bring me [ __ ] but you brought you you
made it
good and comfortable for her and uh with
that
i always thought she was a stand-up uh
dude after that
a guy with a lot of heart i love your
comedy man keep it up
and uh man i want you to get a talk show
again
so anyhow thanks george you're a good
dude man
don't use profanity hey so um
yeah you know what that's a that's a
really good question i mean you know you
and i
we worked together at the punchline in
sacramento and you know that i would
tell somebody hey go get the
you know the last four people at the end
of the line and bring them in like
people that we're clearly not going to
get in yeah all the time so
you know i've done that before and i
paid people's bills
done whatever bottom drinks did the
whole nine yeah yeah so
you know the reason i wouldn't bring you
a drink is because you know
uh you're not a woman and uh you know
she needed a chair
and what woman doesn't need a dream i
thought it's probably with you i
probably
try to bring a five drink so yeah i
appreciate the very kind words about the
stand-up guy
that uh i wouldn't know about that but i
i always have been kind to
why not not always but maybe in the last
uh 15 years more than before well i i've
only been around for
those days but i've seen you do amazing
stuff for people that just didn't ask
for anything
the uh that show was called que locos
mike robles who was a comedian i think
he was out of texas
he uh put it together que locos was on
gala vicion and everybody was on that
thing
all the latino comedians and i think i
was i think
only host or i think mike roberts is the
host i think they asked me to host it
i probably wouldn't have done it if i
wasn't the host but i held out the host
it was one of the few things i did end
up
maybe the first real tv gig i had when i
was hosting something
but galileon was a cable company like a
latino cable company
and i'm going to tell you like if that
cable company had been
handled correctly or had people running
it correctly i think
it could have been like the latino def
jam because
you know gabriel gleason was on there
emilio
rivera uh every kind of you know i think
freddy soto
and mencia wow and uh
um and rudy moreno and
all the guys and you know guys that were
you know
really funny then and didn't get a
chance to
you know go further because you know
it's hard in comedy when comedy is just
comedy but as a latino in comedy
it's uh much much harder so
uh but that was a uh great show they
even had a tour
and those and we did shows i paul
rodriguez was in there too
and um i think actually i think
that i think later on that paul actually
got the idea to do like
you know he got kings of comedy from
latin kings comedy from kings of comedy
of course of course yeah
and then he's screwed us all out of the
money
ah i'm really oh no oh i don't care
hey paul rodriguez you uh all myself and
cheech
and whoever else was on that show i
remember
that far back but uh you know we're not
friends anyways but
so i let's not make it say that money
came between us i didn't like you
and you didn't like me be before or
around or since
the kings of comedy so once you be a
[ __ ] man and pay your [ __ ] debts
essay and there you have it the next
next one
and next hey george my name's simon from
new york city uh i wanted to ask what
is the coolest thing you've ever done
in your comedy career whether it was a
show or being on tv or whatever i just
want to know what your favorite
experience is in your whole long career
thanks man uh thank you simon from new
york
or simone what's up
um uh what would you say it is
i mean i could you know i'd have to say
that performing
in front of obama maybe or that the
presidents
no no way selling out radio city
a number of times got a lot of
got a lot of good ones the sitcom
uh the tonight show
oh i was thinking he was stuck talking
show shows like oh comedy
what's a he i think he said the best uh
you know what i'm gonna say
that's hard to say man i'm gonna say
because
as a um teenager
in san fernando that every day at 10
o'clock
in the summer of 1975 and 76
me and guillermo and andy and ernie and
sometimes andy would drive to hollywood
every day
and we'd walk we'd drive up and down
hollywood boulevard then we'd get out
then we'd go get coffee
and get a donut then we'd walk up and go
look at the stars and then we'd go into
some stores
then we'd yell at putos and then we
would take off and go back but it was
kind of like the outing of the day
yeah and you know when you see all those
stars on
hollywood boulevard you look and see the
biggest names you know frank sinatra
you see uh everybody you know michael
jackson everybody everybody
is on there and then the kinks had that
song
celluloid heroes which i loved yeah and
then you hear that
and me being kind of like a fan of
hollywood you know you know i
found hollywood and all those things
mean a lot to me so i would say that the
thing that means the most to me would
probably be
one of the things that just seemed it's
all been it's all seemed kind of like
anything insurmountable the odds that
something good happens
but i'm going to say that when i would
go
to hollywood boulevard i would see
george burns a star
and i would stand there and look down
and i would imagine that
it said george lopez and not george
burns
and every day i went by and i like
touched it you know [ __ ] latino there
you go go ahead and touch that door for
good luck
right there you know so remember how we
do that yeah i used to walk to school
and put a rock by the thing
uh and uh so i would say that you know
back then
you know because one thing gets the
other like the tv show got the specials
and the specials got
kind of the talk show and then the
animation show got the other movies and
all that stuff
so like one thing builds on anything but
one that's one thing that's like 1975
versus 2006 that's the widest gap
between
wanting something and having it happen
so i would say that
the hollywood walk of fame
on right in front of the kodak theater
by the sephora yeah uh on the day of the
100th episode of the george lopez show
ah
and v ragosa was mayor my cast was there
sandra was there
and uh i johnny grant and everybody was
very happy and then it rained
like you know the first part of the week
and they put a
ten up they put like a tent up there and
then that morning i looked outside and
it was beautiful man i was like wow i
started crying
and then uh you know i was uh brilliant
and then i you know i was thanking
everybody and thank everybody other
thing
and i looked over and i saw the guys i
grew up with god
crazy i started crying i lost it wow the
guys that i would go
to hollywood boulevard with in 1975 and
76.
and i think yeah ah amazing right mayan
was there and i'm
like everybody was there so
great question long [ __ ] answer
and thank you
you know i like all those hole in the
wall places man like you know when we
were going to improv in the 80s
if we had money bernina had money we
would go to uh
we would go to astros on santa monica
boulevard and like
oh man fairfax or right around there so
uh sometimes i would say we would go to
the improv and i mean sometimes i got on
stage sometimes i didn't
and as we were driving leaving the
improvements how much money you have and
you go you know i have fifteen dollars
and if i had like ten dollars to go
let's go to astro so we'd go in there
we'd eat and i still go there i still go
there as a matter of fact i was thinking
about going there
uh in the next few days because you know
that it's just different to me like i
feels like you know i go to carrillos in
san fernando i go
to the panerai fountain party over here
in l.a but you know
astros and the olympic cafe that was on
alvarado i should go there
there's an astros by there's an astros
by uh paramount and there's a holiday
burger which is kind of like the astros
on devonshire right off the 405 and
that's where i would go
with those big ass earrings uh onion
rings that look like you know
uh dune buggy steering wheel yeah so so
so there's a place called
is it called toms or right there on
magnolia i believe that's what it's
called
so i find the places that have like the
great fries
the wonder the great pastrami like
remember that
i think it's great outstanding stuff
yeah wonderful right
so i so from the last the first episode
we did i said hey let's go over to this
place
and as we're driving i'm driving the
range rover i tell you that i had the
cayenne with the
rims that jesse james gave me and that
when i went in there
as i was leaving i scratched the rims of
the cayenne
and those things and as i was pulling
out i
just gotten them and i think that i'm
out of the drive-through and when i turn
you here
and this was like 20045 and i'm like
ah and to me like i left the food
light i need the food i went home i
would keep walking by the car thinking
i didn't look that bad mr superficial
like i scratched you know
i punched somebody in the face i don't
think twice i scratched the rim it
bothers me
you know for the 17th [ __ ] year so
when we're going over there in the range
rover i tell you what i tell you he told
me the story as we're
making a left into it into the
drive-through he's telling me they
started man i scratched my rims
so many years ago i just tried killed me
man my wrist my brand new rims
and then and then i order and as i'm
pulling out i think i'm far enough ahead
and i did it again he scuffed him
i scrapped and i'm and then brian's like
oh and i said no that's not a big deal
and then sign up like
i fall stupid ass does that
i thought i was far enough ahead uh
again
and i turned you know i think and you're
like it didn't sound like it was that
bad the whole half the rare babe it's
just
one of those goddamn black and white
cookies man like one side's black and
the other scrapers white
oh it's so great and then then we get to
george's house and he goes i think i can
i could color that one up with the magic
marker
with the sharpie you know what i end up
using
you know what i ended up using to touch
it up black tone uh black
uh black polish oh brilliant because i
used to do my toenails black when i had
a little diabetic reaction i don't have
that
but you know when i wanted to uh you
know i couldn't get there
for a pedicure i just cover them up you
know sometimes people cover their house
even though they're not fumigating it
just tent it up
we have a surprise guest on the line and
uh is that who i think it is
oh good you know why because i as we
were hanging out with him i thought
this guy would be very informative for
our audience and for
you and i yes to say the least you know
if something happens to you
or you're accused of something and you
have to defend yourself you need a
defense attorney so a defense attorney
can be for something really serious or
for something that
is you know i think eddie will do so so
eddie gomez
eddie uh is our guest eddie how long did
you practice
law um
32 33 years wow okay so and when you
were growing up
did what what fascinated you to what
brought you to law do you think was your
dad lawyer was your uncle lawyer was
your
mom's side family lawyers
no um we we had a family friend that was
an accountant and another family friend
who was a
doctor but my interest in law
happened when i
marched in some martin luther king
visited san francisco i think it when i
was 16 or so or 15
and um it occurred to me in the civil
rights movement
all the movers and shakers were lawyers
and uh
so i thought i want to be a lawyer or i
want to be a doctor
yeah so um when you went to school i
guess
i guess you know i knew i was going to
be a lawyer and i knew i was going to be
a doctor
but you had your smarts you got through
right you got throw easy and you started
to focus on your major and you
had to decide on a college and where did
you decide to go to college
um i wanted to go to the university of
san francisco i was san francisco born
and raised and
i didn't want to really leave san
francisco um
so i got accepted to various schools but
the fact that i got into
university of san francisco made the
choice easy for me
that was great you know didn't bill
russell go to university of san
absolutely um they won an ncaa
championship there
you know what i always thought that the
university of san francisco which
um back then just like i thought the
golden state warriors was a great name
but i also thought that the university
of san francisco
was a was a great name for a college
like
that you know like over there a lot of
things in san francisco like at golf
they have the san francisco club
and uh yeah just really into the city
like you know yeah
um yeah like lacc and yeah so i think
that's one of the reasons why there's
maybe there might be
a rift between you know uh la and san
francisco never color frisco or san fran
oh yeah
san francisco i remember the comedian
uh rudy moreno and we took him to work
with me at the punch line and i said hey
man whatever you do
do not refer to san francisco as frisco
or san fran and his fat ass went up
there
and he said it's my first time in frisco
and i heard all this yelling and
booing and i'm in i'm changing and i'm
like what's the matter and the guy comes
in and close the door behind me goes
he just said frisco stupid ass
okay so and then you had to pick a type
of law
and and why did you pick defense law
because of that because of the march uh
well
well the first thing i did was uh major
at uh in college as an accounting
specialist
because i knew that to become a lawyer
there were a bunch of other steps
and i figured i needed something to fall
back on and i i like doing accounting
and i like working with numbers and i
like saving people money on taxes
so i did that as my major and then
applied to law schools
after that and i
got into the every law school i applied
to
and i went to one in san francisco um
that was unheralded but i i saw the work
they were doing in the community
and i wanted to go to a school like that
that did
work in the community as opposed to just
being a
glorified western harvard or something
like that
yeah i think i've known you 16 years
yeah i i've known you 16 years i don't
think i knew any of this okay so
as a defense attorney what did you love
about it
and what did you not or what did you get
um you know criticized for um being a
defense lawyer
um i love the action i was in court
every day and
when you're talking about your case or
representing somebody you're the center
of attention and i like that
um and i like controlling the courtroom
because that's something i learned in
law school
from my criminal defense teacher
that that you gotta control the law the
courtroom
for your loss if you let somebody else
control it
right wow it's like tennis um
yeah okay so let's um
i've had to hire a defense attorney a
couple of times
uh one was very very hard to hear that
one thank you i know i think you're
right
i remember arsenio said i don't have to
fight because i have a defense attorney
on retainer i thought that was a good
joke
and then uh i actually had to go to this
lawyer with a check for a hundred
thousand dollars just to sit in the
chair
oh wow and then i was going to laker
games and that person came up to me
and just kind of walked by and pulled my
jacket
and then she called me and said sorry i
didn't want to
stand there and talk to you because i
didn't want anybody to know that we knew
each other
because that's a high profile and they
figure that if they know
a defense attorney then you must have
needed the defense attorney right eddie
why would you have a defense attorney
if you didn't have to defend yourself
that's right
exactly and and she was keeping your
relationship confidential
that's right from prying eyes or public
guys
especially at a lakers game so that
makes some sense
i might have not thought of that right
well kudos to her for having thought of
that
okay so so so what what what mistakes do
people make
when they need a defense attorney and
they make mistakes finding one
well the first mistake most people
charge with a crime make
is they talk to the police that's the
biggest mistake
that anybody because
those miranda rights are there for a
reason
and when they give you miranda rights
you should zip up your lips and just be
quiet
and say i want a lawyer before i start
talking to you guys because
police are never gonna
use your statement to exonerate you
or to make your case go away they're
always trying to get
something on you to try to make you
incriminate yourself
so never talk to the police okay and i
think maybe and i think maybe television
shows
or tv makes it look like what the cop's
your friend
and he's trying to help you get off and
but
but the way that a police officer would
talk to
someone who's been accused of a crime is
it remotely similar to what you see on
tv
uh yes it can be but uh
they've some some
dishonest police officers um
don't always play by the rules and
they'll try to
get you to talk in the vehicle
on the way to the uh jail
um and then make it look like oh he just
voluntarily started telling us this
stuff
do you think that that's why sometimes
they take like
they took somebody to go eat and to get
something to eat like maybe they try to
make them like
you know they if they take them in the
car to get something to eat and they eat
and they're in back in the car oh yeah
and then yeah they had some food in
their stomach and they're like yeah you
know these guys these guys don't mean me
any harm they're going to try to help me
yeah and because the next step will be
in in the interview room when they get
to the station
they'll give you the miranda rights and
then say hey i'm just trying to help you
i just
i'm just looking for you to get out of
this you know so
why don't you tell me your version of
what happened um
okay so i think that's a very important
part do not speak to the police officers
about anything
don't even defend yourself or say i
wasn't there don't say anything right
eddie not a word
nothing just say i want to see a lawyer
before i can talk to them
and when you say i want to see a lawyer
they can't ask you any more questions
they can ask all the questions they want
but they'll be all inadmissible in a
court of law there you go
another good point so when you become
uh the hired lawyer do you have to
answer these questions through your
client
at some point before the trial
you never have to answer anything that
your client has told you because it's
all
confidential privileged information so
um
so when you had a so when you had a
client so when you had a client
and you met that person maybe for the
first time how long
was it before you guys were private or
whoever it was and you said okay so
now is the time did you do what they're
accusing you of
typically uh i would
when i would get a case or it would come
to my attention
i would end up going to the jail if they
had not bailed out or were
were released i'd go to the jail and
interview my client
immediately
and and basically talk to them about
what happened why are they there and all
those kind of things
okay would you can if would you ever
have something
that uh a prospective client would say
to you that would make you
always not represent them was there
something that
about any prospective client that you
would not deal with
uh no um
i would take any case because
i felt that i was gonna be
their buffer from getting some inferior
lawyer
or somebody that was gonna dump truck
them
and just uh send them to prison or
something
and cooperate with the cops or whatever
um
because i knew i was a really good
lawyer
a really excellent defense lawyer for
criminal cases
and i knew they'd they couldn't get
anything better anywhere else
wow in terms of representation yeah
that's awesome
what's dumb truck what does dub dump
truck mean oh i'm sorry that's a
a lot of uh people that get convicted
will describe their lawyer as a dump
truck that
they back the truck in and sometimes
they're called casey jones too they're
driving the train
to prison for for the authorities or
whatever and
they're gonna and in a dump truck the
client is in the back of the truck and
then he's to back it into
the jail and then release the the
whatever the
remote control thing is that dumps all
the stuff out of a dump truck and dumps
it
right there so i think that's basically
the
analogy that uh people charged with
crime or get convicted are using when
they caught when they use the term dump
truck
when they read you your rights they say
if you cannot afford attorney
an attorney will be provided to you with
no
charge is a public defender attorney
working in your best interest
uh yes uh i believe so
all the public defenders i knew
were excellent lawyers and the vast
majority of them
were better than the private attorneys
that i saw people getting
i would cringe at some of the lawyers
that i would see come into court
and represent their clients and knew
that public defenders were way
way way better than those people were
so how would the normal person get
through that how would the normal
is there any tip like how would the
normal person know whether to take the
public defender or a private lawyer is
there any way
well in order to get a public defender
you have to meet
certain low-income requirements
or no income requirements and and no
asset
requirements i didn't know that i don't
think anybody knows that because they
make it sound like uh
hey if you need an attorney hey you go
of course i need an attorney well i'm
sorry you don't qualify for one because
you have money and you have this you
have a job and you have that you're not
gonna you're not gonna get a public
defender
never knew that that's right um
and that happens uh on occasion
but uh public defender
officers that i knew about never
checked on the veracity of whatever
somebody put
down on the income statement
um they they wouldn't send out
an investigator and say hey go see where
this guy lives
and see if they got a cadillac in front
of the in front of the place or bmw
or whatever they never checked on
anybody's
income or lack of income sources if the
person said
i don't make a cent and i don't own
anything
we you know they they never got checked
on that's a great tip
and they would be represented they would
be represented by the
defender's office there you go right
there so if you're listening
uh eddie just said that if you have to
fill out
you know and you have uh means but if
you put down that you don't have a job
or any way to pay an attorney one will
be afforded to you
at no charge to yourself so uh if you're
maybe lying already just throw another
lie in there
you've already got one foot in the jail
cell let's just go for it
oh yeah and at least that lies never
going to get you in jail
when people criticized you for being a
defense attorney what would they say to
you
uh typically the the big thing
that the normal uh
civilian who's not in the business uh or
know about the business would
say is oh how can you defend a child
molester
or they'd say how can you defend
somebody
that is guilty or told you that they did
it
how can you do that
and to me it's easy because the
constitution
says that everybody's entitled to the
most aggressive and best representation
they can get
in a criminal case and it's the duty of
the state
to prove beyond a reasonable doubt that
this person has committed these charged
crimes
um and so i took that whole thing
really seriously all my career
i represented people the way i did it
was
i put myself in my client's shoes
and said what would i want in a lawyer
to do for me if i was in their situation
so it was very every case for me was
very personal
so i don't know if you can answer this
but was there clients that actually said
hey i i did this and you go okay this is
what we're gonna do
is that how it works or how or did they
just never say it
no they there were plenty um
maybe maybe 90
of my clients told me they did it um
and then what we'd work on is i'd look
at the police report
and look at any other evidence and
determine
whether they could prove it beyond a
reasonable doubt
and if i saw that yeah you know it looks
like they got a slam dunk case here
against my person who's telling me they
admitted it
and typically they would tell the police
they did it too
um even after miranda writes
and so then you're pretty much uh
handcuffed and then what you're doing is
trying to figure out the best deal that
this person can get
if they're convicted of something or try
to lessen the charges
because right typically i found that
these officers
throw the book at people or or
exaggerate the charges
in contemplation of getting a conviction
of something
even if it's lesser because
there are d.a departments that promote
people by how many convictions they get
oh and they won't promote it unless they
got a certain
percentage of convictions well everybody
in here is shaking their heads because i
think as you were saying that we started
to put the puzzle together in our heads
and we're like you know what
that's why they make they they give you
charges you're like
jeez man i'm going away forever well
maybe you're not maybe you're just going
away for this
because it's you know they've shot for
the moon
yeah and that they do that um you know
basically they have to
have some reason to believe they can
charge that
in theory because
district attorneys are held to a the
same code of ethics that defense
attorneys are held to
although i happen to believe that da's
don't really
adhere to the code of ethics like
like i did at least but if a da
is if someone in the dna office is
um an advocate for
one type of crime and somebody goes in
there with that type of crime if you get
that person in the d.a
it's almost like their goal and their
mission will be to put you away right
yes uh because they do have certain task
forces
that they're called that
are largely funded sometimes by federal
funds
so then the county doesn't have to pay
for that
piece of the budget and the federal
government gets it
and in fact i remember there were da's
that asked me he said
hey can you can we figure it can we
charge something like this on your
client
just so we can get it on the certain
task force because we're federally
funded for that right so you get their
little tally mark
and move on right yeah they will tally
mark and they can justify the federal
funds coming
in and then they don't have to use
county
rep resources so they can tell the
county or our budget is uh
20 million dollars or 120 million
dollars whatever these budgets are
and they can the county can then say
okay
we'll do that and then they know they're
getting a federal grant
for 40 million and they can hire another
10 attorneys for a certain task force
okay so in in closing when you get
arrested do not talk to the police
ask for a lawyer
yes and absolutely every time
and don't tell them how much money you
make or assets you have if you want a
public defender
well that's alleged that yeah that's
a smart way to run that but uh typically
a lot of folks
who get arrested uh
don't have money or are on the lower
spectrum of the income
levels what's the what's the biggest
let's close with what's the biggest
mistake someone who gets arrested makes
well to me it's that uh
if it's not they should have run faster
so they wouldn't get arrested uh if it's
not that then it's talking to the police
i've seen it too many times that people
open their mouth and end up convicting
themselves
eddie gomez thank you for being a part
of
oh my god hi awesome to talk to you
eddie
and because you were a guest and because
you're a guest of oh my god hi
we are giving you a one-year auto
detailing of your car from janky toyota
remember if it goes right it's janky
every time he swings i go janky toyota
okay
if it goes right it's a janky you got a
janky
i'll detail your car all right man
thanks dude i might see you this weekend
out there with cedric
cool that'd be great all right great
talking to eddie have a good one i
appreciate the time man
bye-bye you got it any time it's a wrap
that's a wrap brian you know i told you
last weekend and i appreciate all your
time with me
and because it's the mortality thing i
said but i love you man i love you keep
doing this with me
thank you this is fun this is a blast i
love you i actually love i can listen to
you
talk all day long yeah once good stuff i
can't even [ __ ] listen to you don't
perform
i know exactly i can't get through them
but make sure please if you want to uh
ask george any question that's on your
mind ask him for any advice
it's 818-533-1843
any questions off-limits [ __ ] elliot so
have some respect
but you could ask him we'll filter all
right we're out
thank you for tuning in to oh my god hi
to all your friends wherever you get a
podcast apple spotify
so thank you everybody for listening to
oh my god hi
on all things company
you